[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate
and practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive
any of the bible resources mentioned in
this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's
four 800-835-6747 now here's your host
from amazing facts international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
in today's world doctors order x-rays to
diagnose
all sorts of problems a broken bone
cavities pneumonia
cancer and much much more x-rays are so
ubiquitous we barely think about their
value
but not so long ago a broken bone a
tumor or swallowed object
could not be found without cutting the
person open
this all changed when wilhelm rojan
professor of physics in wurzburg bavaria
accidentally discovered x-rays
on november 8 1895 he was experimenting
with an
induction coil and a partially evacuated
glass tube
when he discovered an unusual ray
capable of lighting up a fluorescent
screen
a few yards away when he moved his hand
between the ray and the screen
he saw the shadow of his own bones on
the screen
because he didn't know what to call the
invisible rays he decided to temporarily
call them
x meaning unknown well the x-ray had
been discovered and the name stuck
news of his discovery spread worldwide
and within a year
doctors in europe and united states were
using x-rays
to locate bullets bone fractures kidney
stones and swallowed objects
honors for his work poured in eventually
this mechanical engineer who had been
expelled from high school
won the nobel prize in physics in 1901
still rojan remained modest and he never
tried to patent his discovery
you know the bible tells us there are a
lot of invisible things out there we
don't yet
understand stay with his friends we're
going to learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
welcome listening friends we are live
and this is bible answers live and as
you can tell from the title of the
program
we invite people to call in with their
live bible questions
and we have lines open and the phone
number if you want to call into the
studio with your question
800-463-7297
that's 800 god says 800-463-7297
we're also streaming the program on
facebook so you can actually
watch what's happening in the studio and
send a question
via the internet and that would be the
amazing facts facebook page
or the doug batchelor facebook page and
we have lines wide open pastor ross so
if they give us a call now really good
chance you're going to get your
call on tonight's or your question on
tonight's program
so give us a call one more time with the
phone number
i am doug 800-463-7297 my name is john
ross good evening friends and as we
always do let's start the program with
prayer
dear father we thank you that we have
this time once again to be able to open
up your word and study the uh
the questions that come in looking for
bible answers and lord we ask for your
spirit to be with us here in the studio
and
in a special way we want to ask a
blessing upon those who are listening
wherever they might be
we thank you lord in jesus name amen
amen
well pastor doug you opened the program
talking about x-rays and
the gentleman who invented the x-ray and
as you mentioned
in the opening statement x-rays is such
a common place now you go to the dentist
and it's sort of routine they take an
x-ray or
somebody comes in and they have a
sprained wrist they'll take up
x-ray and how things would change if
you couldn't see what was happening
inside and i think x-rays eventually
uh new technology gave birth to other
means of
like cat scans and other things right
now being able to see inside the body
but you know i was surprised you
mentioned in the early or the late 1800s
1890s when x-ray was discovered um
how many lives would have been saved had
people known about that technology
earlier a little sooner yeah it's
incredible but you know
you think about it today they they
didn't know about invisible rays that
actually could go through
uh you know soft tissue and um
it's interesting that when they first
developed this technology they were
playing with the right and left they had
no idea that overexposure
could cause you know burning or even
skin cancer
in fact it wasn't until one of thomas
edison's uh scientists who had been
spending a lot of time playing with
x-rays
he got skin cancer and died they started
saying maybe
maybe there's some we need to take some
caution with this
but um it helps us realize that there's
a lot of things that are invisible we
don't know about
you know can you imagine trying to
explain to
you know the apostle paul how television
images go through the air with sound and
picture
i mean it'd be so hard for them to
comprehend that
so when people say i don't understand
how i can believe in god and
he's invisible and how can you believe
in something invisible well we believe
in things that are invisible
every day with wireless technology and
with x-rays and all kinds of
invisible forces that we can't see and
just because we don't yet have the
instruments or understand the spirit
realm the bible tells us
it is very real and let me give you a
few verses romans 1 20
for since the creation of the world his
invisible attributes
are clearly seen being understood by the
things that are made
even his eternal power in godhead so
they're without excuse
so if people say well i can't believe in
god you know paul says look
though he's invisible his attributes of
what he's done is
clearly evident everywhere and
jesus the bible tells us is the image of
the invisible god the firstborn
over all of creation and so um
yeah and jesus said you know i'm going
to send my spirit unto you we might be
filled with the spirit and
it's a very real guiding power
but it's invisible jesus said you know
you can't tell where the wind comes from
and where it goes but
so is it to be born again in the moving
of the spirit
and god is offering that power of the
spirit to each person it's very real
even though you may not be able to
measure it scientifically and we've got
a free offer that can tell you more
about it
we have a book and it's entitled life in
the spirit and it talks about the holy
spirit more importantly
how we can have the holy spirit working
his
miraculous work within the heart and the
life of the believer
we'll be happy to send the book to
anyone who calls and asks again just ask
for the book it's called life in the
spirit
and the number to call if you'd like to
receive that this is our resource phone
line it's 800-835-6747
again that's 800-835-6747
as for the book life in the spirit and
we'll be happy to get it to you in the
mail
if you're outside of north america you
can read the book by just going to the
amazing facts
website just amazingfacts.org
you know pastor doug i can't remember
did we welcome those joining us on
facebook i think
we did your facebook page also on the
amazing facts we can welcome them again
though
all right and you'll notice on the
bottom of the facebook page the phone
number and if you have a bible question
that's the number you want to call
1-800-463-7297
and i think we're ready for our first
caller we have carlos listening in new
jersey carlos welcome to the program
hi welcome hey thanks for calling
um um
i love you guys i've called about three
or four times
um i love your ministry uh my question
is how could you
tell the difference when the devil
um plants a thought in your mind
or if it's just myself like a real
evil thought it's like and i
immediately i'm like my gosh could i
possibly be converted
is my conversion genuine um
well i think i know what you're saying
carlos and
don't despair i think that uh every
single person if we had a little video
screen on
our foreheads that showed everything
we're thinking i think we'd all be
embarrassed
and i've been just shocked sometimes i'm
on my knees talking to the lord in
prayer and i'll have the most bizarre
and sometimes dark thoughts go through
my mind i think lord i am so sorry i'm
talking to you
and i thought that yeah but yeah the
devil you know sometimes it's the devil
sometimes it's just your brain short
circuits i think and
you know all kinds of wild thoughts are
flying around in your head
but uh if you have a thought that you
know is not according to god's will
you just pray and you choose to eclipse
it the bible says overcome evil with
good
in romans and so uh choose to think
about something
better um yes the devil can plant
thoughts in our minds i think that's how
he tempted jesus in the wilderness
it's not a sin to be tempted so if a an
impure or bad thought comes into your
mind just reject it
pray for god's spirit and then think
about good things
you know what i think is encouraging is
often we we will have a thought and
suddenly
no sooner does the thought coming to our
mind but then the conviction comes into
our mind that
yeah wait hang on a minute that that's
not the right thought
and that's evidence that the holy spirit
is also active in working in our hearts
and minds to bring conviction
so we shouldn't get discouraged just
because we have you know somebody once
said you can't stop the birds flying
over your head but you can stop them
making a nest in your hair
so we can choose whether or not to dwell
upon the thought exactly and that's
important
thank you for your call carlos we got
george listening in new jersey george
welcome to the program
hello and how is everybody doing this
week all right doing good
how are you hey well i'm doing fine in
new jersey
time is a little bit later for me than
for you right now you know
but anyway i have a question on of the
use of
shield you know in the old testament
it's commonly translated grave or
hell sometimes in genesis specifically
genesis
37 35 and deuteronomy
32 22 and in light of
solomon's belief of shield being a place
of darkness and silence how is
genesis 37 35 interpreted it's when
jacob finds out that his son joseph was
torn to
bits you know or thought his son was
torn to bits
by a lion and he says that he's going to
go to
shield to his son morning well
i'm wondering it can't be a specific
grave because he didn't
believe that you know joseph was in the
grave so i'm wondering about that
passage how you would look at it
and also in deuteronomy 32 22 it says
uh the fire of god's anger burns
excuse me burns to the lowest shield and
i don't quite understand that passage
either you probably have read
in your studies you know some people
believe shield has two compartments
i'm sure you're aware of that one of
torment and one of um
of paradise i was wondering how this is
in conjunction with
solomon's you know interpretation of
solomon's belief
or we'll do our best yeah a good
question i appreciate that
um well first let's look at genesis and
in genesis chapter 37 verse 35
when jacob says and he thought that
joseph had been killed by some wild
beast
and he said you know i'm not going to be
comforted i loved him so much he was the
firstborn of my
wife rachel that i lost i will go down
into and the word sheol is translated
grave
to my son morning going down to the
grave didn't mean that he would be
conscious there with joseph he just
meant
when i but when the time comes for me to
die and be buried
to the very last moment i'm going to be
thinking of joseph you're never going to
be able to comfort me i can't
reconcile the loss of this beloved son
so the word their grave it doesn't have
a dual meaning
in fact i'm looking at it now in the new
king james version it just says the
grave
um and then you do have deuteronomy open
there
and i think the other one was
deuteronomy 32 22.
and um again i think in both verses it's
simply talking about the grave
i do not subscribe to the concept that
i think you have to put something in the
verse that's not there to say sheol
has a happy sheol which is paradise and
there's a bad
shield which is torment sheol is just a
place of darkness it was the grave
and bibles of david slept with his
fathers and they go to the grave and
they rest until the resurrection
you can read about that in acts chapter
2. yeah the verse you're referring to
deuteronomy 32 22 it says for a fire is
kindling my anger
and shall burn to the lowest hell they
the word shield is translated hell
it shall consume the earth with an
increase and set on fire the foundations
of the mountains
i think here pastor is referring to the
final judgment that comes upon the
wicked
where the earth melts with fervent heat
is weird about
in peter so i think it's talking about
that final judgment on the wicked yeah
and when the laws
are raised for the final judgment it
says they are cast into a lake of fire
so i think god is saying that there's no
escaping the grave will not let you
escape the judgment and
but it's not saying they go right down
to a fiery place
upon the death because the judgment day
is still future
jesus says in john chapter 6 and the
resurrection still future so
we know that that punishment is of the
final punishment and you find that in
revelation chapter 20
and 21. you know we do have a study
guide it's called is the devil in charge
of hell and it talks about the subject
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks the number to call
for that
is 800-835-6747 you can ask the study
guide it's called is the devil in charge
of hell
you can also visit the website
helltruth.com
which is helltruth.com it's one of
amazing faxes websites
there's a lot of resources on that
subject so
take a look at that thanks for your call
george let's see we got carlos
now in fairfield california carlos
welcome to the program
hello pastors how you doing god bless
you god bless you
and your question tonight yeah i do have
a question right now okay it's been
bothering me for a little bit of a time
okay
which is in matthew chapter 3 verses
13 through 17 and then
referring to matthew chapter 11
verses 2 to 7. why is that happening
right there
all right let me read this for our
friends that are listening and this is
matthew chapter 3 verse 13.
then jesus came from galilee to john of
the jordan to be baptized by him
and john tried to prevent him saying i
need to be baptized by you and are you
coming to me
but jesus answered and said to him
permit it to be so for now for thus it
is fitting
for us to fulfill all righteousness and
then he allowed him
and what then the other verse you were
interested in
carlos matthew chapter 11 verses
through 4. okay and is that where he
talks about john the baptist
yeah i think so okay yeah and this is it
says
uh the disciples of john came to him and
john
sent his disciples saying are you the
coming one meaning the messiah
or do we look for another and then jesus
didn't answer right away
he did a bunch of miracles in the
presence of these disciples and then he
says
go tell john the things you see and hear
the blind see the lame walk the lepers
are cleansed the deaf hear the dead are
raised up
and the poor have the gospel preached to
them and blessed is he who is not
offended
because of me in other words don't lose
faith now john was in prison
and he like many of the jews in his day
they thought the messiah was at some
point
going to use his divine power to
overthrow their enemies and bring israel
to dominance as a kingdom again
and john was waiting for jesus to
demonstrate
to reveal to announce here i am i'm the
messiah
and jesus wasn't doing that he was
coming like a lamb
the first time and so john was wondering
did i
make a mistake when i said this is the
lamb of god that takes away the sin of
the world
so john was going through a real time of
testing when he was in prison there but
he was very satisfied with the answer
that came back
i think also past the dead we we find
john realizing that
at least needing to learn that the
kingdom wasn't to be an
outward display at the first coming
there would be the kingdom established
at the second coming
and john didn't fully understand that as
you said that wasn't clear
in the minds of a lot of the the jews at
the time they were looking for someone
to rule on the throne of david
you know and proof of this is even after
three and a half
years of the disciples following jesus
after his resurrection
i think it was philip in acts chapter 1
he says will you at this time restore
the kingdom we've been waiting for you
to restore the kingdom when are you
going to flex your
divine muscles and and make us ruling
the world again like the son of david
and so they it was so deeply ingrained
that uh they just
they had a hard time understanding his
first coming
all right thank you for your call carlos
we've got paul listening in arkansas
paul welcome to the program hello
pastors how are you doing
doing good thanks for calling and your
question tonight
well sir about a month ago i called in
sharing a
brief uh disappointment about an a
friend of mine for three years an elder
a mentor
a senior in the church that he invited
me for
and which i attended for three years and
we had a lot in common we were just
really close and then when he found out
that uh
i believe once they've always saved and
he believed you could lose your
salvation
um he defriended me and pretty much
spiritually threw me under the bus
uh you were very apologetic sharing that
uh
your ministry believes you can also uh
lose your salvation
and uh as i shared with him you know to
me that's all irrelevant i don't believe
the father
jesus our folk and elbows you know uh of
uh uh
you know point fingers you know what we
believe the reason i brought that up
again is because i have a question about
the pre-tribulation but i need to know
does your ministry believe in the
pre-tribulation otherwise the question
i'm going to ask is probably
relevant for an answer all right well
first of all i hope that whatever we
believe is biblical and i think i'm sure
that's what you you meant
but uh so you know what our ministry
teaches
is isn't worth a nickel it's what does
the bible teach
now when you say pre-tribulation do you
mean do we believe that the
rapture takes place before the
tribulation or after
is that what you're asking yeah so let
me just
ask you a question uh so after this is
what i heard about a month ago
i'm a truck right very adamant listening
to suicide like
about a couple weeks ago i heard that uh
there would be
uh several resurrections uh the first
one would be when jesus descends to
receive his church resurrects the
person's sleep and those who are still
alive
then he was saying that during the
pre-tribulations all those that convert
to christianity and die as martyrs
before they go into the millennium they
will be resurrected
to enter the millennium however they
will not have glorified bodies
my question was if there is a thousand
year reign which you know this is the
teaching uh
i follow um
all those who die during that thousand
years
as believers uh will there be another
resurrection
when the new jerusalem uh descends okay
now i think i i understand i appreciate
that paul
um well first let me give you a verse
here uh there are definitely
there is definitely more than one
resurrection because if you look in john
chapter 5
verse 28 jesus says do not marvel
the hour is coming in which all that are
in the graves will hear his voice
and come forth those that have done good
the resurrection of life those that have
done evil
the resurrection of condemnation and
paul says in first thessalonians chapter
the dead in christ rise first so
wherever you have a first
you obviously have at least a second and
we also have a reference to add to that
in revelation chapter 20 looking in
verse 5
it says but the rest of the dead lived
not again until the thousand years have
finished
this is the first resurrection and then
verse 6 blessed and holy is he that is
part of the first resurrection
over such the second death has no power
so
the second death would then be those who
are destroyed because it says they are
the ones that death does have power over
so revelation 20 indicates two
resurrections the first resurrection for
the righteous
the second resurrection for the wicked
as you mentioned what jesus said
all that are in their graves will hear
his voice yeah and so
now we both believe in the millennium so
i heard you reference a thousand years
um a lot of the reformed christians
believe that the millennium
is actually spent in heaven some believe
the millennium
is spent with the saints on earth were
of the belief that jesus said
i go to prepare a place for you if i go
prepare a place for you
i will come receive you unto myself that
where i am ye may be also
and so we live and reign with christ in
heaven during the 1000 years nobody's
dying and we're not reigning over the
wicked
at all would be really strange if the
righteous have eternal life and the
wicked are living and dying around us
and furthermore there's three or four
verses in the bible that say there's a
time coming when the earth is totally
depopulated
jeremiah 4 23 and isaiah and
other passages talks about the slain of
the lord covered the entire earth and
there's no one to lament or bury them
satan is bound in this bottomless pit so
you know the best thing and paul thank
you for listening we're really glad
you're
listening when you're on the road
driving and
if we can send you a study guide on the
millennium
it's got all the verses that we're
talking about now that would give you a
lot better grasp than
what we can give in three minutes now
the study guide is called a thousand
years of peace and it's looking at
revelation chapter 20
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747
again that's 800-835-6747
and again the study guide is called a
thousand years of peace
and paul we can still be friends if we
disagree i promise
all right call us again thanks paul for
your call
we've got joel listening in north
carolina joel welcome to the program
good evening pastor doug pastor ross
evening
um could you please explain and i know
it's a big subject and you only have
three minutes but could you explain the
investigative judgment to me
all right the idea of the investigative
judgment sometimes called a pre-advent
judgment
is based on a simple fact that if jesus
is giving out rewards when he comes
and is that revelation 1 7
behold he comes and every oh and my
reward is with me that's revelation 22.
he says behold i come with the clouds
and my reward is with me to give to
every man
if he's rewarding people when he comes
sun investigation happens before he
comes
peter says judgment must begin at the
house of god
and if judgment begins at us what will
be the end of those that obey not the
gospel
and then ezekiel 9 also talks about a
judgment that
begins at the house of god the verse
you're referring to there it's an
important one first peter chapter 4
verse 17
that says the time has come that
judgment must begin at the house of god
so pastor like they appears in the bible
to be some kind of a sometimes referred
to as an investigative judgment
that occurs before jesus comes to
determine the rewards
uh of course the reward of the righteous
is everlasting life
the bible also says that everyone is
rewarded according to their deeds right
so there is also some kind of uh
judgment that gets meted out against the
wicked
and so just before jesus comes we have
this investigative judgment
and based on a very important prophecy
in daniel chapter 8 verse 14
uh there the judgment is referred to as
the cleansing of the sanctuary
we know that began at the end of that
year time period and i know this is a
long study but in 1844
there was a great revival in north
america and not only north america but
it spread around the world
where people were focusing on the
prophecies of daniel and revelation
and they began to see verses for example
in revelation 14
fear god give glory to him the hour of
his judgment has come
and so there was this revival in
understanding what this judgment is
and even in daniel 7 it says the
judgment was set and the books were open
that's right
so there's a heavenly judgment that
takes place now the great white throne
judgment
happens later it's after the
resurrection and the second coming
can we send you a lesson on this joel
hopefully that would help a little bit
and i think the uh the lesson that deals
with this is called right on time
and it's talking about that judgment and
uh we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks
it's a fascinating study especially if
you like math called right on time we'll
send it to you as talks about the
judgment and some very interesting time
prophecies
in the bible pastor ross what we go to
it looks like we got one minute you know
what i'd like to do before we go to our
mid-break
i want to tell all of our friends that
are listening that amazing facts is
about to launch
a very exciting program it's called the
revelation
now we're going to be broadcasting from
right here at our headquarters
a special series of studies talking
about where we
are in bible prophecy and revelation now
everything is about to change and we'd
invite you you can jot this down very
quickly
revelationnow.com check out the website
and if you'd like to host having this
bible study in your home
or your church group or your home church
or your small group
it's just the perfect opportunity and it
is free
and so if you'd like to engage in a
bible study spectacular
going through an incredible panorama of
bible prophecy
then you're going to want to be part of
the revelation now programming listen
starts october 23 and we'll be doing it
several nights a week
all the way through november 14.
and so we hope that you'll check that
out right now
so don't go away we're just taking our
bottom of the hour break we're going to
come back
you can still call in with your bible
questions 800
god says we'll return in a moment
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever
and includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on bible answers live
order your copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past alexander
the great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy 150 years in
advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug
batchelor explores the most striking
bible prophecies
that have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time dot com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
god and his plan to save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live welcome back
listening friends
and if you've tuned in somewhere on the
way this is bible answers live where you
can call in with
bible questions and we'll do our best to
give you honest
to the point uh faithful bible answers
my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross and we're going to be going to
our next caller and we've got betty
listening
in california betty welcome to the
program good evening thank you for
taking my call yeah
um i was hoping you could share some
insight with me on who the 24
elders are in revelation 4 10.
yeah you know it it's a little bit of a
mystery
but there's two prominent theories out
there and
of those two theories i'm inclined to
think in the same way
that adam is called the son of god and
he was sort of the leader of this world
i think the lord has other unfallen
worlds
the number 12 in the bible or the number
24 often depicts
leadership and uh you know you've got
the
uh the uh 12 apostles and you got the 12
judges
and when you go into the books of
deuteronomy and chronicles it talks
about 24 sometimes
that were in they led in worship in
the temple and so these 24 elders may be
leaders from other unfallen worlds
around the throne of god
that hold some high position that's one
theory the other theory is they may be
some of those who were
brought to heaven during the
resurrection of christ
but you can read in job chapter 1 where
it says there was a day when the sons of
god
came to present themselves before the
lord satan came also
from earth god said where'd you come
from he said i came from the earth
here's this heavenly meeting where god
is meeting with these sons of god
and some scholars have thought well
these are
like the 24 elders i don't know if you
got anything to add to that pastor ross
no i think that kind of summarizes you
know it it is interesting when you find
the first reference to the 24 hours in
revelation
you'll see it in revelation chapter 4
when it's described in the throne room
and jesus appears in revelation chapter
as a lamb as it have been slain so
that's led a number of bible scholars to
feel that the 24 elders would indeed be
the representatives of the unfallen
worlds those sons of god that you read
about
in revelation oh sorry in job now we
have a book we can send you that
talks about this it's who are the sons
of god and
if you like that book we'll send it to
you for free it's actually the whole
title is called
angels aliens or adopted but if you just
ask for
the book on who are the sons of god it's
talking about the 24 elders in there as
well and i think you'll enjoy that
the number to call is 800-835-6747
and again ask for the book uh the 24
elders
and we'll send it to anyone who calls
and asks if you're outside of north
america and you'd like to read it
just go to the amazing facts website
just amazingfacts.com
we've got jonathan listening in colorado
jonathan welcome to the program
uh yeah hi um i got a quick question i
guess
on matthew chapter 17.
okay um i came up with two questions if
that's okay it's from the same chapter
all right let's start with the first one
my first question is from verse 14
through
17. uh kind of tells the story of
this man that took his son that i guess
it was possessed
to jesus and um verse 17
jesus uh i guess i'm just kind of
shocked the way jesus
entered it just it says perverse and
faithless generation
how long shall i bear with you exactly
how
uh how long should i put up with you um
i i kind of want to know why i know that
why does that sound a little harsh well
that's a good question
let's talk about it um when jesus comes
down the mountain and he sees
the pharisees are disputing and the
scribes with the apostles and the court
they're sort of mocking them saying you
can't cast out this devil
and you can also read see if you read
the same story
in mark it gives you a little more
insight if you read in mark chapter 9
it says when he came to his disciples
and this is verse 14
he saw a great multitude around them and
the scribes disputing with him so
the scribes were picking on the apostles
because the nine apostles that stayed
behind when jesus
went up the mountain with peter james
and john they were being bullied
and they just refused to believe in
jesus so that's why jesus
kind of was pretty strong he said you
faithless generation
well you know other times jesus said the
scribes and pharisees hypocrites
so he was sometimes a little hard on
these religious leaders that were
misguiding the people
so did that to help a little bit
jonathan uh yes i just i thought
i thought he had said that to the to the
man that brought his son that's why i
was you know
he he was very merciful to him
so and you have a second part of the
question
yeah just in the beginning about the
transfiguration of jesus
uh what what does that mean like does
that mean that he
he took like a different form or is that
like the form he's in within now
or was he like i guess in a different
body or well good question no it was
still
jesus but um you know jesus divinity
the the god aspect the spiritual side of
jesus where the glory the son of god
when he was on earth he laid that aside
and you can read about that i think
that's in philippians chapter four
made himself of no reputation um he laid
aside his glory
when he went up the mountain god
re-glorified him he was transfigured
means that there's a transformation
and the main transformation that it
mentions he began to shine
brighter than the sun and i think the
words that are used by matthew mark luke
are all a little different but it's
basically saying that
brighter than the sun at noon there his
clothes were whiter than any soap could
ever whiten them
and christ began to glow with glory kind
of like when moses came down the
mountain from talking
to jesus or from moses talking to god
his face was shining and so this is
where christ's
glory was basically unveiled when god
met with him and said this is my
son and so that's all that means
he christ has you know he still has a
human form now
but he is glorified now you read about
that glory
if you want to see what jesus looks like
it's what revelation chapter one right
and also in ezekiel and daniel
talks about the glorified christ you
know jonathan we do have a book it's
called
um the two witnesses yeah the glorious
mount of transfiguration
and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who asks for that uh the number
again is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
the glorious mount
and we'll be sending that out hey
jonathan can i ask you a question before
we let you go
uh yeah did you hear my sermon yesterday
i did not you know what i preached on
i know after this very passage matthew
17 14
so it's interesting i just thought that
was an interesting coincidence i
preached on this yesterday
but anyway all right well god bless
thanks
you know jonathan if you can you might
want to take a look at that i i know
it's available on pastor doug's website
or facebook page
and it's also archived at the amazing
facts live stream
website so uh and it's called
i don't remember what did i do oh i hope
yeah hope was harassed by hell
there you go i knew that your title
yeah so yeah that'll be if go to doug
batchelor facebook page you'll see our
church service from yesterday
uh neoma is listening from texas
miami welcome to the program hi thank
you
yes um my question today is
what does the bible say about surrogacy
if anything all right well good question
um technically mary
carried a baby that was
conceived by the holy spirit for god
so i guess a person could argue that she
was a surrogate
now are you asking because you're
wondering if it's okay to
adopt her to have a child are you
thinking of being a surrogate for
someone else
actually i can't carry and we have
one child already via a surrogate
and we're about to attempt a second
and i just wanted to make sure well let
me give you some scriptures okay
yeah i think it is okay um there may be
some that will disagree with me but
you'll remember when sarah was barren
she brought abraham hagar
and said i can't have children have a
children
hagar perhaps can carry a child for me
now the reason that was a bad idea is
because abraham took his wife and so all
suddenly had two wives
but in the event where a woman is
basically
uh processing the baby
for another mom and she's not going to
go through the
the emotional turmoil of handing that
baby over there's nothing wrong with
parents adopting a baby it's just it is
a little bit of an odd situation
and often a mother after carrying a baby
for nine months when the time comes for
her to hand it over as
you know you've probably been through
this uh she may
think long and hard about wow this is
tough i don't think there's any
biblical uh problem with that and i know
some cases past today
a family member might be the surrogate
mother for
someone who can't have a child so um
yeah now i'm sure there are some
challenges as you mentioned
but if this is something that you prayed
about and um
you have someone who's willing to do
that for you
yeah reasoning
yeah so there's there's really no moral
dilemma someone is basically helping you
to uh have a child as as close as you
can to the family tree
thank you neoma i am saying that right
yeah we've got eric listening from
new york eric welcome to the program uh
yes green and pastors
my question good evening my question is
uh
chapter 12 in numbers uh
one through five where miriam and aaron
uh
was angry with moses because he had
married ethiopian woman
yes and that later on in the
chapter the lord cursed and made a leper
but what my question is
what happened to his otherwise sephora
yeah let's uh let's talk about that
there is some ambiguity in this verse
it could be now zephora was a midian
knight
midianites may have had some ethiopian
heritage
it could be zephora had died let me
rephrase that it could be
that miriam and aaron were giving
zephora a hard time because
moses had married someone that was not
an israelite and it could have called
her a midianite
and a an ethiopian they would have not
seen a big difference in that ethiopia
back then
covered into the arabian peninsula as
did the midianites so that's one theory
the other theory is
that sephora had died and moses had
every right like abraham did to take
another wife
but she was an ethiopian keep in mind
when the children of israel came out of
egypt
not only did the israelites go but there
was a mixed multitude
that went with them and that believed in
jehovah and moses may have found
someone among those people that uh
he married so i don't know if you got
any
insight on that yeah you know i think my
my understanding
would be the first interpretation that
you gave that um
the ethiopians back then were more
arab-like
in their complexion and uh as you said
ethiopia was a much larger area of land
back in those bible times so could very
well be his his first wife but uh aaron
and miriam were being punished for their
prejudice
and uh marion was forgiven of course she
got leprosy for a week
but they also were challenging moses
authority and not respecting his
authority and uh also the the um
i guess it's just plain old racism is
what it was back then
does that help eric that helps a lot i
thank you very much
all right hey thanks so much we've got
tony listening in florida tony welcome
to the program
good evening pastors i love your show
i love your show i have a question on i
have a question on the
book of leviticus where it talks about
the fools you can eat and the food you
can eat
now i know pork is the the one that
people when they hear that they can't
eat pork no more
some of them ignore it even they claim
to be good christmas but they ca
keep ignoring it my question to you is i
know god knows our heart
and if they keep ignoring it and and
they really know about it
are they going to be saved well whether
it's
whether it's the foods you eat or
any truth um god
judges people based on the light they
have now let me give you some examples
if if i should go out and take another
wife while i'm still married to karen
i'll be judged by the lord in the end
and i'll be judged by karen
shortly after because i know that
polygamy
is wrong but there are people in the
bible that will be in heaven that had
multiple wives
because they lived in an age where god
winked at their ignorance and what is
that verse acts 17
30 at the times of this ignorance god
winked at
there are people there'll be people in
heaven who ate pork they didn't know
there'll be people in heaven who maybe
kept the wrong day as the sabbath they
kept the first instead of the seventh
well they didn't know god judges us
based on
when we know truth jesus said if you did
not
see then you'd be without sin but since
you see your sin remains
and so um if a person knows that the
bible says
pig is an abomination do not eat it
your body is the temple of the holy
spirit and this is not a
a law for jews it was a law god gave
noah god made a distinction between
clean and unclean way back for noah
and even peter three years after christ
ascended to heaven
peter says i have never eaten anything
common or unclean
and so uh you know they were still
practicing
these laws even after christ so
you know i think that when a person
knows the truth if we go against our
conscience
that becomes sin anything that is not of
faith is sin james says so
is that making sense tony no no i i
believe me it for me it does i just
wanted to hear from you guys like i have
it
as a tool to use when i show somebody
else
yeah well show them the scriptures and
you know whether they follow or not
we've got to be careful not to be their
conscience
i mean it may take them a while to kind
of digest this truth
but yeah whenever we know god's will
if we deliberately and high-handedly
resist his will
it turns into sin you know we the verse
you refer to pasadena acts chapter 17
verse 30.
it says at the times of this ignorance
god winked at but now
he commands all men everywhere to repent
so that is after a knowledge of the
truth
god wants us to follow the truth and
ultimately it's for our own good
yeah and you know we have a book we
don't very often uh
hand this book out but it's a great book
and
talks about this it's called it's got an
intriguing title it's called death in
the kitchen
yes talks about uh how god wants
us to take care of our bodies and of
course we'll send that to anyone
who calls and asks just ask for the book
death in the kitchen
the number is 800-835-6747
and just one more verse and this is an
industrial strength verse tony
paul says in hebrews chapter 10 verse 26
for if we sin willfully after we have
received the knowledge of the truth
there no longer remains a sacrifice for
sins but a certain fearful expectation
of judgment
so if a person continues to persist in
sin when they know what god wants
they're walking on dangerous ground all
right thank you for your call tony we've
got
jim listening in wisconsin jim welcome
to the program
oh is that me that's you john welcome oh
sorry my she must not have heard my
first name's tim but
tim all right we've got jim down here
all right well welcome to
that's okay well um i feel blessed to be
on
so my question comes from uh genesis i
want to say 316
when god is talking to eve about
multiplying her sorrows and i believe
it's in childbirth that he's referencing
and then it says again in genesis 5
4 about adam's uh
like his his length of life before he
had seth
and it says they had other boys and
girls other
children yes yes so my question
for the genesis 3 16 one
before they fell did they have children
before they fell yeah before they fell
into sin probably not
because um it talks specifically about
a cane and able being born and it seems
to be chronologically after they were
evicted from the garden
and it talks about king and abel making
offerings for sin
so you would think well this is you know
after sin
so it doesn't appear that they were in
the garden very long before
they were tempted and they fell within a
matter of months probably or less
and um yeah the children came later
and probably she you know as curse said
then they
she brought forth children with sorrow
but yeah good question
thank you tim yeah you're welcome i just
because i had that
that feeling like maybe when cain after
cain murdered abel and he went out
uh so i can't even remember the land now
he went out but when he went out to the
other
nod to not or yeah um you know where did
all these other people come from that's
the big question one of my friends keeps
asking me
well like kane took assistance they know
they're not
it tells us adam and eve it only
mentions the first born boys but they
lived you know
adam lived hundreds of years and they
had just gaggles of kids probably and
there's nothing wrong with marrying a
sister back then when everything was
perfect adam and eve technically had the
same parents
so it wasn't until later with genetic
problems god
said they shouldn't be marrying close to
the family tree
all right thanks for your call tim we've
got uh henry listening in new york henry
welcome to the program
yes greetings how are you
good uh my question is
uh i kept a secret for 60 years
and i kept another secret for for
this october next 69 years uh
it it has to be with two members
of my family and the rest of my family
does not know about it
should i reveal it to them or start
leaving guards hands
all right good question now it's kind of
hard to counsel
you on that because that would you know
if the secret is that you were gossiping
about them well i just forget about it
and ask god to forgive you
uh if the secret is something that
you're being convicted
it's something more serious that um
someone was wronged
and you know you feel you should reveal
it
if if god can be glorified by your
confessing that to somebody
then you should do that but and you
might want to get some local counsel
yeah you know the biblical principle is
we want to attempt to make things right
if we've wronged against someone now in
that case
it might not necessarily be making
anything right depending upon the
situation
sometimes it's better to leave with the
lord and just pray that god will work
things out but
again that's where we need to let the
holy spirit guide and as pastor
mentioned it's good to seek christian
counsel on something
if it's bothering you let me give you a
couple of hypotheticals like i said if
you gossiped about somebody i just
say lord forgive me and leave it alone
no one's going to be helped if you stole
from somebody and even though it's been
a long time you might want to confess
that because you don't want that on your
your record when you go to the kingdom
and offer to repay as far as you could
so it depends on what the effect of what
the offense is and
you know there's there's young people
that's probably done things or they're
older people now but they did
things in the youth uh they feel bad
about it they can't find the person try
and make things right you just
leave with the lord and if you can make
it right well then yeah it's probably
worth doing so that would be the
guidance there thanks for your call
henry uh let's see we got uh
another caller from florida we got
herbert listening from florida herbert
welcome to the program
thank you so much yes thanks for calling
um i've listened to a lot of your
sermons and i really appreciate them
well it thinks it's strange
that a couple callers ago they talked
about
a swine's flesh and an abomination
and i wondered if there was different
degrees of abomination
deuteronomy 22 verse 5
um mentions another abomination
and i see it in the church
and i wonder if you could clarify that
all right and you say deuteronomy 25
22 verse 5 22 verse 5. okay i can read
the passage that i've
got to hear it says a woman shall not
wear anything that pertains to a man
nor shall a man put on a woman's garment
for all who do so
are an abomination to the lord your god
absolutely the word of the lord doesn't
change
and there should be a distinction in
clothing between men and women
and of course we're living in a society
that is uh
you know totally um attacking
those distinctions god made the
differences between men and women should
be
encouraged and celebrated and we're
living in a culture right now where
you're you're uh you're at risk of being
imprisoned
if you tell boys they should be boys and
girls they should be girls
but god said that he didn't want to blur
those lines of distinction
and that it was an abomination when we
do and he uses the same phrase when he
talks about
uh same-sex relations
god made them it says male and female
and uh there are distinctions and
it it helps to create a whole you got
the strengths of the male you got the
strengths of the
of the female and in a marriage type
relationship
you need both if you're going to have a
healthy strong family now
styles between of clothing you know in
different cultures there are different
styles
and styles constantly go through
different fashion changes and
and some are more practical than others
you know you don't want to
dress so oddly that you're a spectacle
but christians should dress modestly
and there should be a distinction in the
clothing between men and women
that's easily discerned thank you for
your call uh maybe we have time for one
more we've got caleb listening from long
island caleb welcome to the program
hello pastor doug basswood how are you
impressive rovers how are you guys doing
good we got about 60 seconds can we do
it
yes we can do it okay so i've been
watching online
and people that preaching the word and
stuff like that by the way your ministry
has been helping me a lot thank you
crazy um but so someone was preaching
and saying like if you put you can't
pray the reason why a lot of people's
prayers
aren't getting answered is because they
pray to
they're not they they you can't pray to
jesus you have to pray directly with the
god
but me as i know jesus is the bridge
between you
us and god can you pray to jesus
and two um what's the difference between
worship and praying is it all right is
it
i'll do the same thing yeah let me let's
get to that real quick before we run out
of time
uh typically in the bible it tells us to
pray to
the father in jesus name but there are
one or two places in the bible where
prayers are directed to jesus so it's
certainly not wrong
when stephen was being stoned and i
think that's chapter 7 of aches
of acts he says lord jesus received my
spirit
and the new testament ends by saying a
prayer
even so come lord jesus so there's
nothing wrong
with praying to jesus the pattern you
usually see in the new testament
is we pray to the father in the name of
christ the son
hey thank you caleb good question and we
do have a book we'll send you a free
copy called the name of god and it talks
about
praying in god's name and what that
means
and that's
out the upcoming 800-835-6747 revelation
now everything is about to change go to
revelationnow.com
and we'll study his word together with
you next week god bless
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
the statistics are grim millions have
been infected by coronavirus
thousands have died race riots have
broken out on streets
political tensions are at an all-time
high does the bible have anything to say
about the times in which we are living
hi friends this is pastor doug batchelor
many people are wondering
if the world's about to implode some are
fearful that global events point to a
coming crisis
unlike anything we've ever witnessed did
you know the bible book of revelation
actually speaks about the days in which
we're living now
and it contains a message of hope if we
would only listen
that's why i'd like to invite you to
revelation now
decoding the bible's greatest prophecies
in this multi-part series
i'll be sharing relevant truths for our
time from the last book in the bible
coming october 23rd to learn more visit
revelationnow.com
can't get enough amazing facts bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy
more truth-filled programming visit the
amazing facts media library
at aftv.org at aftv.org
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material
all free of charge 24 hours a day seven
days a week
right from your computer or mobile
device visit aftv.org
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling 1-844-215-7000 that's
1-844-215-7000
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6600
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org